hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster where all of a sudden there's
this mysterious monorail station and I
wish I had a good excuse for not
recording this but frankly I don't
really it's actually took upwards of an
hour to build the roof of this thing
alone
and it was a very embarrassing turn of
events where I just kept building stuff
and removing it and was even
live-streaming it and that was horribly
painful basically the most important
point is that it's here and it gives us
a pretty good head starts into the rest
of this video because many of the things
which I'm making in this video are just
kind of all over the place there are
many little things that still needed to
be done to actually finish the German
area and that's what I'll be doing in
this video
everything from the foliage to the
buildings to the terraces to the little
monorail should be finished after this
video except for very small things
including the cars on the monorail and
the cars on the car ride and the station
of the coaster which are things that I
am just progressive mating on because I
don't think I can really do them yet or
I just don't want to do them yet either
way
I want to move into some other things
pretty quickly especially with the
deadline coming up quite closely and I
hugged some deadlines very tightly with
some earlier projects Alf aim was
stressful and grizzly Valley turn out to
be pretty stressful so yeah I at least
like to pretend that that's not gonna
happen this time around anyway just
doing a little bit of foliage underneath
the station in which you can practically
go really wrong with only thing that you
can really go wrong with is placing too
much foliage like on the inside of
buildings or inside caves and things
like that
I do wanna keep my foliage underneath
buildings and on the rocks quite simple
just a bit of very simple grass and
mostly looking textures no flowers or
anything like that because obviously I
do want to get those things in in the
places that actually get some sunlight
and yeah this little plaza was also
still looking a little bit empty so I
wanted to add some flowers to that I am
trying with all my might to not go
overboard with the flowers even though
I've already gone a bit overboard with
them I still to leave some areas with
just trees and grass and as you can see
some areas with just open Ross as well
not to make everything look too flowery
if that makes any sense
which is not just because a theme park
with just flowers everywhere wouldn't
make too much sense it also just kind of
helps to leave some areas open and
especially the little area inside the
plaza seemed like a very good place to
leave with a bit more open grass and the
little grass patch underneath the
monorail next to the restaurants I
wanted to keep open just to sort of keep
that sight line of the restaurant quite
clear make it really like the restaurant
is kind of looming over a little hill
instead of being sort of overarching I
love these trees and offenses and paths
are still a bit of an annoying thing so
this is a bit of a yeah a crooked fence
over here just quickly built on top of
the hill just to at least give some sort
of a cue idea I didn't want to quite
make the queue I'll do a few pieces at
the time because it's pretty much
impossible to hook those up well it is
impossible to hook those up to path
pieces without any problems but um in
the end I'm not really sure how well
that bread texture worked out so I'll
probably revert that back to the stone
texture of regular pots now next thing
that I wanted to do is actually work on
this little balloon right here since it
didn't really have any kind of scenery
around it and the entrance of it was
still one big yellow gates and I don't
really like yellow gate so that needed
to be covered up but then again this
thing that's supposed to cover it up is
quite bulky and a bit of an eyesore in
its own rights so I at least wanted to
add all sorts of stuff around it to make
it look a little bit less bad it still
probably looks bad in the end but um
yeah if something looks bad you can
always just keep adding stuff onto it
until you can't really tell if it's bad
anymore or if it's just one big mess of
detail and now in an attempt to actually
make it look a bit better and in a
serious way also add a bit of realism to
the ride because there wasn't really any
kind of operator booth for it
it's not that I saw one um I wanted to
add a little house next to it which is
where the ride operator could possibly
if there were such a thing
sit and operate the ride with its little
window to have an overview of the ride
and that's why I built this little house
but at the same time it also helps to
make the entrance gates not seem so out
of nowhere and seem so breaking the
entire surrounding it's a very simple
house with just a very similar style to
what I've had before it just kind of
helps to bring out the entrance a bit
more and for the realism of the ride
it's not that much otherwise just a
little bit more experimentation with
like different proof pieces I do quite
look I do quite like adding all of these
different trims on the sides of the roof
pieces just to not make them so alone so
it's simple and actually make them look
more like proper roof pieces as that's
why I wanted to add some of those door
pieces around the sides of the roof give
that little trim around it and I also
wanted to do is actually make a fence
what's like the one thing that I'm
really happy with as a result of me
building that monorail station and
taking two hours to do so is that I'm
very accidentally came across a trick to
make new fences which are quite simple
it's just a bunch of signs sunken into
whatever kind of border you want to use
but it is quite nice it does have a bit
of a fence like texture - it's not the
best-looking fence but the most
important thing is that it uses some
slightly different colors different
textures and different shapes than many
of the fences which are made out of the
much more common pieces in the game and
yeah this fence is more or less used to
get a bit more variety into the fences
it is not the best looking fence but
hopefully it'll make the other fences
look a little bit less repetitive it
also kind of helps to cover up that very
standard sort of a theme las' fence of
the ride itself because the ride does
come with a sort of very generic fence
which doesn't really make it fit into
the very rustic look of the park in
general so it kind of helps to cover up
that ugly fan
in favor of a little bit well more
rustic Fence at least and the same goes
for all of the details around it there
was still quite a bit of space around
here and that space wanted to be filled
with a couple of planters a couple of
benches and some new lanterns again for
a bit of variety on it as well and I
think it was Brandon who actually had
the idea to take this round the thing
that I used as planters before and
actually use it as a little bin by not
really putting any plants in it which
actually works quite well so I figured
that once I have some little bins around
there as well I will definitely fill in
the rest of the park with little bins -
it's just something that I didn't really
do up to this point because I still kind
of want to figure out how to best make
little bins actually look like little
bins but that's something to worry about
at some point in the future anyway the
next thing I wanted to do is make this
house over here which isn't really
anything it's just a bit of decoration
but it kind of helps to transition from
the main streets into the transition
into another area because just ending it
with this one big building over here
just seemed like a very very sudden sort
of stop of the Main Street facades there
and this building also doesn't really
look too great if you look from this
perspective so I kind of wanted
something that could it's sort of sort
of transition from the main streets into
what is basically going to be a more
open area without any buildings and one
lower building that sort of goes on for
a little bit longer and has this open
place underneath it with a bunch of
scenery next to the plot seemed like a
pretty good shape to sort of get that
going and also a nice way to get some
extra scenery in around the paths and
what is next to this going to be a small
path to the German - German area what to
the Dutch area which I want to have run
around here on the corner at some point
in the future then aside though it is
pretty much a building like any of the
other ones so far simple stucco walls a
bit of wooden framework on it and on top
of that a roof made
a ton of doors which I do have to say I
would want to use this roof for the
touch and the Scandinavian area as well
for texture reasons as since they are
well generally coaches with a lot of
buildings that have red tiled roofs the
only issue with that is that I am really
beginning to feel very terrified really
at the prospect of the frame rates that
this is probably gonna give at some
point in the future and though it may
not look like it I am at least trying to
keep my Polly's as low as I can and
using this roof as little as I can is
one point in that so I mostly want to
use it in the most visible buildings in
the most visible places which is why I
wanted to use it in here but still I
don't want to use it quite too often
we'll see how the frame end is gonna end
up anyway that's probably a worry for
later to be quite honest so down here at
the bottom I'm just decorating it with a
bunch of wooden posts some windows and
some simple timber stuff I wanted to
keep this open and actually add some
scenery in there which isn't even my
idea I should mention that this is
actually largely modeled after some
buildings in Tripps real which are kind
of like showcase buildings of miniatures
and scenery that's in them and while I
don't really have any kind of puppets or
anything to really turn this into some
sort of interactive thing on the side of
the path it does help to get some extra
scenery in and transition from the main
streets so I still wanted to make
something a bit similar to those
buildings and this is what it ended up
becoming and it's also a really good way
to just get an excuse to add all sorts
of detail because it is a very simple
building it's really not that
interesting on its own and just a good
way to add all sorts of scenery in and
around it
to at least make it and look much more
interesting than it really is in the end
same goes for much of the ivy here I
have to say that's kind of a tip that I
would give but sort of want to be quiet
about because they're the kind of tips
that are more about how to be lazy and
how to appear good without actually
being that good I would almost reckon
just covering any kind of empty side of
a building or a side of a building which
you don't really know what to do with
with Ivy if that's what it fits the
theme is actually a really easy and
wonderful way to make things look a
little bit better it's kind of like
putting trees in front of the building
that you don't really like that much or
just placing restaurants everywhere
which is something that I'll get to
later in this video over here I was
struggling with the path system for a
very long time so I decided to screw
that and skip forward in time and the
moments I stopped recording that's like
I got the path layout done at once which
was a bit strange but yeah moving on I
wanted one more addition to the park and
I didn't even come up with it myself
I really have to credit a comment for
this and I forgot who commented it so if
you were that person I am very sorry
about forgetting your name but somebody
actually left the comments and said that
I should add am a tree to this park and
I have to admit I completely forgot
about it and it's a really great idea
they're basically there are trees that's
many European cultures they raise up and
well guess in what month for some reason
I'm not actually entirely sure what the
reason is but I assume it has something
to do with well farming because may is
like the beginning of summer anyway but
yeah it's it's a very common thing
especially in Bavaria and some Alpine
countries so I wanted to get a Maitre in
and it's quite simple as well just one
big wooden pour with on the top of it
what's left of the tree and a bit of a
like decoration they really have varying
decorations and there are all sorts of
may trees but I wanted to go for quite a
simple one since it really seemed like
the most feasible thing to do here now
alongside the flat rod here I had a lot
of empty space and I didn't really have
any kind of idea what to do with it
for a while I thought of just making it
forests but that's something that I just
wanted to avoid because it would seem
like a lot of wasted space I was
thinking about buildings and extending
the mates
all the way into this here but
realistically that is just way too many
buildings for such a small park and
almost all of the buildings that I do
build I do want to make sure that they
have some some kind of function and
having a huge Disney style main street
would definitely not fit in this kind of
Park so that was out of the question
and yeah one last resort kind of thing
that I was thinking of was to build just
another small restaurant over here not
really a full-fledged restaurants but
just a small sort of snack corner with a
terrace on the outside and the reason
that I wanted well that I was hesitating
to actually do so is that this would be
the third restaurants in what is quite a
small park and I really felt like two
would be about the magical number four
for the size of this area and this is
quite close to the other restaurants as
well so it is a little bit dense but it
is in the end what I thought would look
best for this flat ride and for this
part of the park and that's why I
decided to just put a little snack shop
in there or a Shack I suppose it is and
just have some terraces on either side
one is raised just to kind of give a bit
more sort of play for almost
terraforming height difference into the
area because if that were the case I was
very afraid that this would turn out to
be very sort of flats large stretch of
paths and flat rides and that's what I
wanted to avoid and one side of the
terrorists is just a regular sort of a
very small Terrace which is just very
close to the ground that's basically it
and the shake itself is quite simple as
well just very standard sort of roof
structure here with a rectangular little
shack underneath it which I don't think
yeah I'm not gonna actually add a
functioning restaurant on the bottom of
it which in hindsight maybe I do want to
do I'm still not 100% sure because it
does kind of make things a bit of a
hassle but I can do it there isn't
anything sticking through the building
and technically speaking even though
there are already functioning
restaurants in
I'm quite close to it I might actually
make this functional at some point in
the future right now though it is just
going to be a bit of a decoration
because in the end it it is always kind
of like a puzzle to figure out how to
put everything together if you do put a
store inside of it because you will have
to have it path connect to it and you
can't have any walls or anything go
through it and not having anything
inside of this does make it possible to
basically well come up with the entire
look of the thing except instead of you
know getting a store of one tile and
having to build around that so I was
quite happy to not have to do with the
store here but I might actually place
one at some point in the future in any
case I figured I would have some cosmic
cow signs on top of it not to have
clickbait for the people in the park and
we think that this is a cosmic cow store
but because it seemed like the most
fitting kind of thing it isn't exactly a
big restaurant just a very small corner
where you could get some ice cream or
something like that and cosmic cow with
their milkshakes seem to be about the
next best thing though I'll definitely
be adding some extra signs and stuff at
some point in the future this was just
kind of a place order of that's what I
kind of want to do with this in the
future I may actually have decided to
change that around a bit now skipping
more of that time lapse for a little
more interesting segment I quickly
wanted to make the terrace over here out
of some pieces which have already made
especially at this point you do kind of
get to notice how much easier it is if
you save everything that you're using as
a separate building like the more things
you've already made in the park the more
things you can just copy over from other
sections of the park so it just very
quickly took the fence from the
playground here but all of the tables
and parasols and chairs that I made
earlier in there one planter and that is
basically the terrace finished in a very
small amount of time so it really does
come in handy it can be a bit of an
annoying thing to do very early on in a
map but especially later on if you've
got all these things saved it becomes a
lot easier definitely one of the reasons
why I'm very much looking forward to
alpha 3 as well with the blueprint
sharing function
which will make the lives of just about
everybody a lot easier but I'm not sure
if this is really the best time to talk
about my height before alpha 3 the next
thing that I wanted to do here is add
some flowers because I didn't have
enough flowers in the park yet I love
myself some flowers what I really didn't
have enough in the pockets is actually
arranged flowers that sort of are
arranged in a kind of decorative way
many of the flowers are just but beside
the paths and rides in a more random
fashion just all sort of stuck together
but I didn't really have any kind of
flower arrangements as you would see
them in larger parks like Disney
especially Epcot does it a lot and why
certainly didn't want to do it on the
scale of this need this is going to be
the entrance into what is going to be
this kind of Navy and area so it is
quite a significant point of the path
system so I wanted to decorate it quite
a bit add all sorts of flowers and
decorations around it make sure it also
looks quite a bit significance and it
did sort of turn at this Plaza over here
into a very open area especially with
having nothing in the middle of this
grassy section I ended up putting a well
over here which I forgot the word for
earlier on but I got it no worries I saw
your comments but yeah I wanted to place
it well over here in the end it did turn
out to make this Plaza quite open it's
not very Foresti anymore but we'll just
see if that ends up being a good thing
or bad thing once I get into the rest of
the area yes so it's time for that part
of the video again and there is plenty
to talk about here since I am not really
sure about my future plans for this park
one of the issues is that I actually
managed to throw up a little bit more
space than I was planning to relative to
what my Park size actually is that I
started with which I'm gonna have to
well chalk up to my terrible drawing
again but this means that there isn't
really much space for the Scandinavian
area right now since this is well just a
very very crammed sort of stretched out
rectangle on that I still have left over
here so I might just extend it a little
bit into this direction make it a little
bit larger
because I do still plan to make an rmc
coaster over here which again I'm not
really sure how well that's going to
work out since I will have to use the
bnm Trek for it would have actually
liked to use the zero trike for it
instead since the zero Trek is a bit
more similar to an RM c Trek but um you
can't do inversions with it so what's a
an RM see without inversions technically
you can do inversions with it but it's
gonna well require a lot of magic tricks
to actually get it to do all of the hang
time and things that are MC coaches do
so um yeah I'm gonna end up using a beam
input that's still have to figure out
how I'm going to do that entire side of
the park and there is also going to be
there a touch section with what is
certainly going to be a bnm family in
vert since there is still not a bakoma
inverts in this game mm-hmm just giving
out some wink-wink nudge-nudge there but
you know got to work with what we
actually have want to have a BM family
inverts in here and see how that kind of
works its way around that area there's
still plenty of room around here
especially for the more widely set up
areas that I do blend to make those
points of the park since they are a bit
more new and the German section is kind
of a bit of a forest
I don't know showed off too much yet but
this is basically what it looks like I'm
actually quite happy with how it all
sort of came together one of the biggest
issues or one of the biggest like
obstacles that I felt I was really
afraid of was it not really fitting
together and just ending up being this
incoherent mess that sort of looked good
on paper but doesn't really in real life
but I'm quite happy with how it overall
transitions into the different areas and
this is basically how it looks for every
part of the park one thing that is still
a little bit sketchy is the station
which is still a work in progress and
what I also still have to do is the cars
for the monorail and the car ride I
actually got some designs sent to me so
thank you for that I will have to figure
out how I'm going to do that but it's
something which I'm procrastinating on
I'll get that done at some point in the
future but first I need to figure out
how to do these areas in this shape and
this time because there isn't really
that much time left for alpha 3 which is
at once a great thing because I'm
looking forward to it and on the other
hand I do not get these this Park done
before that time arrives anyway that's
it for today I hope to see you guys next
time in which our attempts to make an
arm see closer and we'll see how that
goes
thank you guys for watching